ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah ah ah ah face president dilma
I come here to say that I'm ashamed of
you not only I as everyone here
unfortunately you are in that moment 15
to magnify Brazil politically
saying that you have made improvements that
really the glass is very good but it is
a lie you embarrass us or
does not represent us then dilma
Unfortunately I turn my back on that
this cup that was giving the
Brazilian eyes not to me
so the president ended up having the
lady unfortunately i will not be back again
I congratulate Dilma congratulate or
president lula the former president moon eu
congratulations yes, because they had
courage to have exteriorized
the best you have in the heart of
You're all employed and two years my
salary knows what is zero mine that
if my request is that we workers
We pay a lot of taxes, it's less
taxes for us please do not have
many other prompting agents to move forward in
issue is of the civil rights of
families and homosexuals in a way that
and she spent a lot of money
Cupcakes I'm Brazilian and I'll always have
I love Brazil, I love being Brazilian.
only I think she should have
invested half of this money to
more important things than
to be doing the country seemed like a
Perfect world tourists will just talk
I'll tell her before the end of the
mandate is to legalize marijuana
she improved berta no op what you
acquired a corrupt political system and
simply reproduced the same
practices that macho male pigs
chauvinists have been doing for centuries in
our country
Shame on you, shame on you.
woman's penis is bigger than
any other man will take it in the
education in dona dilma
the queen of the prostitution of corruption
of this nation that dependence that we
we have if we work to sustain
the first world because she has a car
She has to go up and down us.
poor do not have staff
I wanted to thank you for your example.
by his strength from his youth
fighting for Brazil and defending a
Brazil, which is more democratic and
every day then instead of trolling
here I want to say thank you president